tel est passé
[Musique]
aniki
c'est une comptine qui à destination des
écoles maternelles qui nous a beaucoup
marqués qui nous avait beaucoup
interpellé parce que c'est un véhicule
beaucoup de stéréotypes sur les sur les
chinois
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'à cet âge là on n'a pas
conscience des choses il ya beaucoup de
moqueries on se moque de la différence
on peut imaginer une classe de
maternelle avec avec un chinois dans la
classe on va tout le monde à prendre la
comptine et ça sera ce petit chinois qui
s'appelle pas forcément de chang qui va
être dit victime de ces moqueries à la
création à la cantine suffit qu'il ait
dû durer à la cantine qu'on lui refasse
qu'on l'appelle chang
il ya beaucoup de clichés qui circulent
sur les personnalités tic des clichés
propres hommes d'eddie chez propre femme
la femme plutôt gentil docile qui veut
dire oui à tout l'homme qui toujours
aussi ce cliché de gentils mais aussi
qui n'est pas viril qui est
informaticien qui fait du kung fu enfin
qui fait des qui fait des nems alors que
l'inm ce n'est pas ce n'est même pas
chez moi pour ceux qui ne savent pas
donc il y voit là il ya plein de clichés
qui circulent à la fois sur les hommes
et les femmes air asia tic qu'on va
confondre forcément avec des chinois
qu'il ya des clichés qui vont qui vont
dire par exemple que les chinois ont
beaucoup d'argent sur eux ils se
baladent avec beaucoup d'argent sur eux
il ya eu une agression en août 2016 d'un
couturier chinois à david haye qui
s'appelle turc charline trois agresseurs
l'ont essayé de voler l'argent qu'il
avait sur lui on l'a agressé
malheureusement il a succombé à ses
blessures
j'ai 26 ans aujourd'hui j'ai quitté
l'école maternelle il ya à peu près 20
ans et je me dis qu'il ya toujours ce
genre de stéréotypes qui sont encore
véhiculée est donc ça fait 20 ans qu'on
a peut-être pas assez agi on se dit
qu'aujourd'hui il faut agir davantage
pour définitivement supprimé cette
comptine ou d'autres stéréotypes sur les
asiatiques
c'est un racisme qui est vu comme moins
grave parce qu'il est banalisée parce
qu'on l'a pas assez dénoncé
ça fait depuis surtout les années 80
qu'il ya beaucoup d'asiatiques en france
la première génération n'a pas pu
dénoncer ces choses là mais c'est la
nouvelle qui va prendre le relais pour
les dénoncer
au fur et à mesure je j'espère que la
société française va prendre conscience
de la gravité de ses actes